hey 42 here the world is addicted to a
potent psychoactive drug it is by far
the most popular drug in the world the
average person consumes over 300
milligrams of it every day yes it does
stuff to your brain in your body that
will shock you I am of course talking
about caffeine but how does caffeine
work and what's the worst thing it can
do to your mind and your body and could
it kill you firstly how does this good
work how does it perk you up in the
morning well every minute you are awake
your body is releasing a chemical called
adenosine into your bloodstream
adenosine can be forced off asleep
pressure the more adenosine that is
built up in your system the higher your
sleep pressure and so the more you feel
the need to sleep after being awake for
about 12 hours adenosine levels in your
body will have built up to such a level
that you will feel an overwhelming need
to sleep if you stay awake for a further
12 hours or more the adenosine levels
are so great that you will struggle to
keep your head from dropping off and
your mind from slipping into brief
moments of blissful unconsciousness the
only way to reduce two levels and rid
your body of this adenosine buildup is
by actually sleeping during sleep your
body systematically breaks down the
adenosine particles in your blood and
flushes them out of your body caffeine
works by directly battling with
adenosine adenosine affects your brain
by latching onto neural receptors when
it does this you feel sleepy but
caffeine molecules are able to latch
onto the exact same receptors as
adenosine in doing so it takes the place
of the adenosine and thus blocks the
adenosine from activating those
receptors like standing on the wrong
side of an elevator in a tube station
causing a buildup of pissed off
businessmen behind you the only
difference is that caffeine doesn't
results in your head being smashed in
with a briefcase most of the time the
caffeine therefore fills your brain into
feeling awake and alert at least for a
little while the problem is that
although adenosine is being blocked it
doesn't ever go away
in fact whilst the caffeine sits in your
receptors for several hours
blocking adenosine like a fat unwanted
squatter adenosine is still being
released in droves into your bloodstream
increasing in volume but unable to
actually latch onto and affect your
brain caffeine has a half-life of about
six hours so after around six hours
after ingestion your body starts to
break down the caffeine which frees up
your brain receptors again when this
happens the tidal wave of built up
adenosine suddenly floods the newly
unblocked cell receptors in your brain
like a torrent of sleepiness this causes
you to crash after feeling awake only
moments earlier your energy levels will
suddenly plummet into a deep hole of
lethargy this is colloquially referred
to as a caffeine crash and it's why
drinking caffeine to keep you awake
behind the wheel of a car late at night
can be deadly when the caffeine crash
inevitably hits but what if before the
caffeine crash arrives like an unwanted
train of disappointment you were to
drink more coffee topping up and
renewing the caffeine levels in your
system
well like before the new caffeine would
rush to your cell receptors and occupy
them thus blocking the adenosine for
longer still and prolonging your feigned
state of awakeness and alertness and
what if you were to repeatedly take more
caffeine to put off sleep indefinitely
well the issue here is that eventually
the adenosine will build up to such
overpowering levels as your caffeine
intake will no longer be able to stop it
from activating every receptor in your
brain and like a levee breaking
sleepiness will flood your brain but
your mass caffeine intake will likely
have kicked off a dependency cycle where
your body constantly needs more caffeine
to hold back some nasty withdrawal
symptoms
repeat this dependency cycle enough and
congratulations you are addicted to
caffeine the day after this caffeine
party you will wake up from your
dropped boughs asleep with a headache
low energy dizziness and you'll
generally be in a bad mood
you'll also still feel really tired
because although you slept you didn't
really sleep
let me explain we all know that caffeine
can stop us from drifting off to sleep
if we drink it too close to bedtime in
fact a study found that even when a
large coffee is drunk in the afternoon
it can cause you to lose an hour of
sleep that night but when you do
eventually fall asleep if caffeine is
still in your system then the quality of
your sleep will be abysmal in fact if
you drink enough caffeine before bed you
may as well have not slept at all if you
consume caffeine less than six hours
before bed it will still be rushing
around your system during sleep this
reduces the amount of deep sleep you
will receive which is the sleep stage
during which your body repairs muscles
boosts your immune function and
increases your energy levels for the
following day basically all a really
important stuff so a cup of coffee the
evening before will cause you to feel
groggy
the next morning long after you've
awoken and long after you drank the
coffee now we all shook down coffee like
it's the tears of Jesus but apart from
keeping you up at night what is it
actually doing to your body and can it
kill you within 15 minutes of drinking a
double-shot cappuccino or flat white
that contains around 130 milligrams of
caffeine your heartbeat will increase
rapidly and your stress will be
heightened because caffeine stimulates
adrenaline production this can make you
feel anxious or give you the jitters in
some people who are extra susceptible to
caffeine it causes heart palpitations
insomnia headaches and hallucinations
but if you drank enough coffee would you
die well sorry to disappoint all you
masochistic thrill-seekers out there but
not really it will take a healthy adult
male with no pre-existing conditions
just 10 grams of caffeine to kill them
although what constitutes a lethal
dosage depends on the individual the
highest known caffeine overdose that was
survived was when a 39 year old female
attempted to commit suicide
by taking a staggering 100 grams worth
of caffeine pills but caffeine is so
dilute within coffee beans and thus
liquid coffee that you would need to
drink about a hundred and fifty eight
shots of espresso before you kneel over
dead the problem is even when drinking
only espressos continuously the human
stomach is unable to fit that much
liquid into it eventually you will have
to slow down or just stop knocking them
back and that will give your liver just
enough time to break down some of the
caffeine in your system and thus save
your life
it would technically be possible to die
from a caffeine overdose drinking coffee
alone but it would be really difficult
and some people just wouldn't be able to
do it especially if you're the kind of
person who gets bloated halfway for a
pint however people were serious
pre-existing heart conditions would have
to drink a lot less coffee to die and
could suffer cardiac arrest or slip into
a coma after just a couple of
cappuccinos but even for people who
aren't aware of any heart conditions
caffeine can and does kill quite often
actually it's not coffee that's the
enemy however it's when caffeine comes
in other forms specifically energy
drinks and pills a sixteen-year-old
David Allen crime sadly discovered after
he drank a latte an energy drink and a
mountain dew in a short space of time
the excessive caffeine caused a heart
arrhythmia and he dropped dead at school
cases like these are rare but they
almost always happen as a result of
drinking energy drinks or taking
caffeine pills and not from drinking
coffee alone in 2014 in the u.s. 1,700
people died as a result of consuming
energy drinks a single energy drink in
of more than twice the caffeine content
of a cup of coffee
to make matters worse a study found that
most major brands of energy drinks
contain far more caffeine content than
what is advertised on the label also
powder caffeine or caffeine pills are
even more dangerous one teaspoon of
powdered caffeine is equivalent to
twenty six cups of coffee if you already
worry about the effects of too much
caffeine you may be one of those
incredibly exciting people who orders
decaf well I've got some bad news for
you
decaf doesn't exist there are various
methods of decaffeinated coffee on an
industrial scale but none of them is
capable of removing a hundred percent of
the caffeine from the be a cup of
decaffeinated coffee still contains
anywhere from two to 14 milligrams of
caffeine if you do drink decaf you're
even upstairs Tim pot or you are
extremely sensitive to caffeine and the
tiniest amount makes you hallucinate
that's your hands have turned into
lobster claws if so then fair enough
because that sounds rather frightful but
what if you're the opposite to caffeine
sensitive what if you could have a
superhuman power that caffeine would
have little to no effect on you well
maybe you already do are you the kind of
person who can drink five cups of coffee
over a couple of hours and hardly feel
the effects at all can you drink coffee
just before bed and drift off to sleep
just fine well you may have a unique
variant of a gene human DNA has a gene
for just about everything how tall you
will be wherever you like seafood and if
you unfortunately have a nose the shape
of a mushroom but scientists have
recently discovered that there is a
specific gene that determines how your
body will react to caffeine it's called
cyp one A two you'll remember that one
you either have a fast or a slow version
of this gene those of the fast version
have a different enzyme for breaking
down calf
that is more efficient and it can
metabolize caffeine four times quicker
than those with the slow version this
essentially means that fast metabolizers
can drink four cups of coffee and feel
about the same as someone with the slow
variant here only consumed one cup but
which variant of the gene you have will
also dictate whether or not drinking
coffee is good or bad for your health
when a group of 2,000 adults who had all
previously had a heart attack
participated in a study a shocking
conclusion was reached it was found that
drinking four or more cups of coffee per
day increases an individual's risk of
heart attack by 36% but only if they
have the slow variant of cyp one A two
drinking four or more cups per day
resulted in no increased risk of heart
disease for those with the first variant
of the G but should you actually be
worried about how much caffeine you
consume
well Lajoie is still out on this one but
all studies points to quantity being the
deciding factor more than four cups of
coffee per day has been linked to some
ill effects on your health and could
possibly be carcinogenic but if you
stick to less than four cups per day
there is strong evidence to suggest that
coffee can blow your risk of type 2
diabetes interestingly a study conducted
at Harvard showed that those who drink
decaf only reduce their risk of diabetes
by around sixty percent of the risk
reduction enjoyed by full caffeine
consumers so it indicates that it's
caffeine specifically in the coffee that
is playing a large part in the health
benefits of the drink coffee has also
been linked to lowered rates of
depression Alzheimer's heart disease and
even certain types of cancer also in a
way that may have never occurred to you
before by abstaining from drinking
coffee you could actually be harming
your health how well unless you're
extremely sensitive to caffeine drinking
coffee or it's caffeine
containing sister T throughout the day
keeps you hydrated the common
misconception that Coffee dehydrates you
is well a misconception it simply isn't
true coffee is a diuretic sure which
means it promotes increased liquid loss
from your body through your urine but
that means almost nothing because this
diuretic caffeine is swimming in a huge
mug of water so the small amount of
water expelled from your body through
the diuretic effect is replaced many
times over by the liquid in the coffee
resulting in a net gain of water in your
body unless you only drink espressos
which have very little liquid but the
same caffeine content so the Italians
are all screwed although they're not
because it's common in Europe to drink a
glass of water with an espresso and so
should you
if you're smart even a small glass of
water will easily cancel out any
diuretic effects from the espresso a
study found that a regular sized cup of
coffee is almost just as hydrating as
water even more so if you add some milk
because believe it or not milk is
actually more hydrating than water any
negative effects of caffeine are far
outweighed by the negative health
effects of not drinking enough water on
a daily basis and when some people
choose to give up coffee or tea
they often don't replace it with another
drink at least not one which they would
drink is regularly throughout the day
which means overall they're consuming
far far less water each day which is
definitely harmful so drink up I say but
make sure when you do drink coffee it's
darn good coffee because life's too
short for bad coffee do you know what
else life's too short for browsing the
internet unprotected
without noord VPN the only VPN to get a
perfect score on PC Mac Nord VPN have
kindly sponsored today's video they have
thousands of superfast servers in over
60 countries Nord VPN uses and
military-grade encryption and has
absolutely no data logging it works on
any device Android iOS Windows Mac Linux
you name it seriously I even run this
thing seamlessly on my android TV to
watch content from around the world I
travel a lot and I often do sensitive
work on my laptop banking messaging
private documents etc in coffee shops
hotel rooms and public spaces but I
always use naud VPN in these instances
because it's easy for hackers to
intercept your packets over public Wi-Fi
and see everything you're doing online
Nord VPN however double encrypt your
data so you can use any Wi-Fi connection
4G or 5g and know you're completely
protected and your data is secure click
my unique link in the video description
to get 75% off a free year plan and
enter the code 40 at checkout for an
extra month completely free thanks for
watching subscribe for a new video every
week and a big thank you to the sponsor
Northey p.m. don't forget to check them
out by using the link below